south of tripoli 24 miles south and the
rebel advance through areas previously
loyal to gaddafi is effectively at an
end tripoli to all intents and purposes
is taken the highness advance though is
the battered and scarred urban landscape
of days of fierce fighting in the
streets compounds and housing estate of
the capital the rebels have flushed
Gaddafi's militia and its mercenaries
away to them now the spoils of war from
military compounds the battered
technicals towaway pristine artillery
pieces whatever it's called looting or
redistribution there are now thousands
of weapons circulating amongst the
population unused to the chaos that this
could bring
but the rebels are in jubilant
victorious mood they've won and they
aren't going to let anyone forget it as
you leave the city and head through the
suburbs the landscape changes but not
the rebel control the chemist brigade
camp once as feared as babbles easier
itself has fallen emptied of everything
useful the NATO air strikes made this
stronghold of Gaddafi forces impossible
to defend it's not totally finished yet
it's not totally secure but one mustn't
undertake before she's an incredibly
short period of time without way outside
of central Tripoli into the southeast
they say what they develop reporters
literally run away these are the men of
the Misrata Brigade who arguably changed
the course of this revolution by forging
their way capital at the start of the
week filling up with petrol they're
heading further south chasing the last
50 trucks of Qaddafi mercenaries who
passed through here overnight the
streets belong to them and they're
chasing their foes down it pause only to
remove yet more ammunition and armaments
from a bewildering number of stores that
Gaddafi forces cased for what they
probably thought would be an unlikely
retreat when 7's Libya has changed
beyond recognition the regime has fallen
Tripoli is dangerous but secure what an
incredible week